la sphère pierre ménès est en train de
prendre une nouvelle dimension lundi le
journaliste venait s'expliquer sur notre
plateau quant aux propos qu'il avait
tenus dans une séquence non diffusés du
documentaire canal + je ne suis pas une
[ __ ] je suis une journaliste dans
cette séquence jeudi une sean connery
celle hors frais des explications que
certains ont jugé plus convaincante et
qui n'excuse pas le comportement qu'il
aurait eu avec certaines femmes
le minimum c'est vraiment de faire
profil bas et de reconnaître qu'on a
créé un dommage et se remettre en
question aujourd'hui cis porte france
qui s'est exprimé sur twitter quant à la
faire nous suivons attentivement les
fait préoccupant reprochés à pierre
ménès nous examinons activement la suite
de sa relation avec les exportent en
effet depuis 2010 est qui amène est
prête sa voix aux commentaires du jeu
fifa dont l'entreprise est le
développeur et l'a fait n'importe quoi
aucune chinoise suite à l'apparition du
hashtag ménès out
beaucoup d'internautes demande son
éviction alors comprenez vous les appels
au boycott concernant pierre ménès
alors ça c'est vrai que ça aujourd'hui
c'est encore voilà c'est encore rebondi
vous vous dites non guillaume non je
comprends pas les appels au boycott en
revanche je trouve que la réaction de me
laisse porter les mesures et pour une
fois il s'est pas fait virer tout de
suite et 18 voilà on étudie la situation
on regarde ce qui se passe on analyse
les éventuels témoignages donc pour une
fois il ya une réaction mesures risquent
fait pas virer immédiatement
donc tant mieux j'avais de plus en plus
c'est que c'est plus guidés par la
trouille et le fait d'avoir une mauvaise
image que par une réelle mauvaise je
suis d'accord acquise à ok c'est vrai
que c'est guidé par la trouille voilà
après ils font ce qu'ils veulent et
iliad a pris les trouve ça normal en
voilà mais c'est vrai que je suis un peu
d'accord avec toi il a ses pas et voilà
enfin guidé ses pas il pas fait pour les
bonnes raisons
voilà c'est ça ouais sauf que petit côté
eu un problème avec avec neymar qui
était la tête des images
oui absolument les débats ils ont enlevé
les mares du premier du premier écran du
jeu donc c'est passé une telle est sa
peine la prudence s'éclater norman moi
ça me choque pas du tout d'accord vous
delphine vous trouvez non moi je trouve
que ça va ça va trop loin tout ça ça
prend vraiment une ampleur quand il est
venu aux jo sur le plateau moi il m'a
convaincu c'est vrai qu'elle diffuserait
qu'on n'avait pas eu votre avis
là-dessus alors oui il ya une différence
entre draguer et embrasser soulever la
jupe certes mais francesca quand elle
est venue hier il me semble bien parler
elle n'a pas fait trop monter la
mayonnaise elle a dix qui était elle
était choquée sans être choqués de ce
qui s'est passé mais je trouve que là ça
va vraiment trop loin mais maintenant ce
qu'il faut mettre à jour pour tout le
monde c'est complimenter hockey par
contre on ne touche pas on ne va pas
vers la personne
moi je me suis dit si le soir je rentre
et je dis ok je me suis fait soulever la
jupe
bah ouais mais pas d'accord quoi je suis
ok c'est ça alors justement regarder
parce que il ya eu un truc avec estelle
denis rire dans l'équipe et on l'a
l'extrait les chéris voilà l'extrait de
regarder vous dites on peut complimenter
pas regarder même complimenter elle l'a
mal pris et estelle denis regarde
aussi dernier 19 ravissant vous avez
droit gut a terminé sans surprise très
bas n'ont pas fait attention surtout
vous dont sa mère dominique desseigne ce
soir voilà c'est vrai bon alors rigaud à
estelle mais il ya beaucoup de gens qui
ont été choquées par sanction prison je
le dit gilles un trait moi je suis très
choqué par ça oui estelle denis
franchement qu'elle ne donne pas son
point de vue par une certaine lâcheté
dacquois dire à elle c'est la grande
copine de pierre documents d'un vrai
elle ne prend pas qu'est ce que vous
dites dures à des mecs comme toi tu
étais amis aussi avec malgré tout j'ai
donné mon point de vue j'ai donné mon
fils qui est contestable alors mais elle
n'ose même pas donné son point de vue et
les brownies avec des blagues vaseuses
avec ses chronos moi je suis extrêmement
choquée je trouve que deux sa part
franchement je ne m'attendais pas à une
telle lâcheté j'appelle ça non elle
avait fait un premier tweet qui était
très bien où l idée attention avec le
documentaire de marie portolano qui est
formidable il faut pas dit il ya 99% des
journalistes sportifs qui sonde équipe
formidable qui son équipe très voilà qui
sont pas forcément des gros bourrin
alors travailler car en plus donc je
trouvais que c'était bien justement
cette nuance et ne pas mettre tout le
monde sur le même sur le même piédestal
après moi je suis un petit peu d'accord
il ya une sorte de de private joke parce
que c'est la grande amie de pierre menez
qui est un peu délicate gens ont peut
pas rire de tout mais en fait c'est ça
le noeud du problème ni tout n'a pas
changé ça a libéré la parole mais non on
ne peut pas je le redis enfin on va
conjuguer on va conjuguer le vert
pouvoir dans tout passé au présent et
futur
on ne peut pas soulever la jupe d'une
chine est touchée le cul ça ne fait pas
seulement voilà et c'est pas mis tout
cas changer la donne voix juste que ce
n'est pas possible se voit alors ça
c'était oui quesnoy samouka moi c'est ce
que c'est le genre de blagues qu'on
pourra faire en privé mais peut-être pas
en public parce que je pense qu'elle n'a
pas pris en compte les émotions que les
personnes ont vécu et ont peut-être mal
vécu venante pierre enfin moi je pense
que c'est pas très cool pour eux pour en
plus c'est sûrement des copines elles
des collègues quand je te laisse un très
bonne à jeter notre bière le rapport
avec cette blague
quelque chose qu'on aurait fait en privé
mais pas en public elle a fait
énormément rire nicolas qui sont bons
mais je dis moi ce que je suis gêné
parce qu'en fait on remet pas le truc
dans le contexte c'est à dire qu'il ya
quelques années motion je n'excuse rien
et s'assure au monde excuses
je n'exclus rien et en plus je dis que
c'est un problème d'éducation parce que
moi franchement mes parents ne m'ont
jamais permis d'un parc d'ester oui mais
en remettre
il faut remettre le druide dans le
contexte 1% et un lance pierre ménès il
a fait un truc à quatre cinq six ans est
aujourd'hui une espèce de meute qui
s'amène sur lui que dis je suis désolé
c'est la réalité
estelle denis skalli c'est une vanne
mais à un moment donné si on peut plus
dire à la télé at elle dit qu'elle est
mignonne rsa cela me dérange elle fait
un second degré agir a dit non pardon
nicolas mais pas mal pour moi tu
comprends pas c'est qu'elle fait pas un
second degré non enfin d'où elle fait un
second degré par rapport à l'épisode wii
un ménez de la même manière comment on
reçoit plein ton plein d'invités ici est
très souvent
cyril vadi aussi bien chez les garçons
vous êtes ravissante vous êtes très
jolie vous êtes charmante monsieur
madame il n'y a aucune ambiguïté et ya
aucune sensation de gêne
là c'est juste pour dédouaner son copain
excuse moi et ça le mettrait j'aime pas
comme ça moi ce que j'aime bien c'est
qu'elle montre que dans ces histoires
c'est pas tout noir ou tout blanc elle a
un positionnement qui est nuancée
d'ailleurs allé dans le documentaire de
marie porto n'aime donc elle dénonça
elle a raison de dénoncer des choses qui
sont choquantes 1 elle a droit aussi de
dire que on vit aussi dans une époque
qui est un peu aseptisé là c'est ça que
j'aime bien c'est qu'elle est nuancée
dans ce cas les murs de quelqu'un qui
est coincée et qui sait très bien que
quoi qu'elle dise ça risque d'être mal
interprétées donc moi la boutade me gêne
pas du tout donc c'est de la lâcheté
c'est ce qu'il faudra dire on essaie
d'ailleurs pas l'équipe qui va racheter
m6 oui a ironisé sur la polémique alors
qu elle aurait mieux fait de s'indigner
plutôt à laquelle a participé aux docks
de canal plus après je pense qu'elle a
voulu dit alors c'est vrai que comme les
copines avec ménès je comprends presque
sacré non dit et ça crée une bonne idée
mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui c'est
vrai que comme le dit guillaume
on va pouvoir veut pas se mentir ça
devient extrêmement compliqué maintenant
on réfléchisse en permanence et c'est
tout ce qu'on va dire et c'est vrai que
ça peut devenir un problème parce qu'il
refuse et moi il ya aussi des femmes
avec on peut échanger avec qui on peut
parler et c'est effectivement j'aime mon
cocon dit un compliment qu'on dit une
chose sympathique on y voit pourvu
qu'ils ne disent pas dans trois ans que
j'ai bon je comprends très bien ce
qu'elle veut dire ce n'était pas le
moment ce n'est pas le bon timing
voilà c'est tout dire on risque d'aller
en prison voilà ça c'est pas mal hein
c'est pas pareil à un truc là qui passe
les rations à lors des finales oui mais
en fait voilà dans les dires il n'y a
aucun souci on peut complimenter on peut
même complimenter lourdement du temps
cap du temps qu'on ne va pas toucher en
fait c'est juste ça il faut pas qu'il ya
une intrusion physique attend des mots
qui font mal
il ya des oui mais tu as des gens qui
sont lourds naturellement lourd tu vois
d'après où est la lourdeur l'a dans les
mots c'est pas si grave que ça